AND THIS IS "THE FIVE."
>> ♪ ♪
>> BREAKING NEWS.
PRESIDENT BIDEN MISHANDLED EVEN
MORE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
A SOURCE CONFIRMED TO FOX NEWS
AIDES FOUND ANOTHER BATCH OF TOP
SECRET FILES AT A LOCATION THAT
IS NOT HIS FORMER OFFICE.
THE WHITE HOUSE BEGIN A CHANCE
TO COME CLEAN ABOUT THIS DAMNING
NEW DISCOVERY BUT REFUSED TO
COMMENT.
>> HAS HE LOOKED INTO WHETHER
ANY OTHER DOCUMENTS HAVE BEEN
TAKEN TO ANY OTHER OFFICE?
>> I WON'T SPEAK TO.
THIS I WILL LET THE PROCESS
CONTINUE.
IT'S AN ON-GOING PROCESS.
I WON'T TO SPEAK TO THIS FROM
HERE.
IT'S MORE PRUDENT AND
APPROPRIATE FOR MY COLLEAGUES AT
THE WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL.
>> JOE FINALLY BROKE HIS SILENCE
ABOUT THE INITIAL BATCH OF
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
CLAIMING HE HAD NO CLUE HOW THEY
ENDED UP IN HIS PRIVATE OFFICE.
>> I TAKE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
SERIOUSLY.
I WAS BRIEFED ABOUT THIS
DISCOVERY AND SURPRISED TO LEARN
THAT WERE ANY GOVERNMENT RECORDS
THAT WERE TAKEN THERE TO THAT
OFFICE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS THE
DOCUMENTS.
I TURNED OVER THE BOXES.
THEY HAVE TURNED OVER THE BOXES
TO THE ARCHIVES.
WE ARE COOPERATING FULLY WITH
THE REVIEW.
>> DON'T EXPECT ANY ANSWERS FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE PRESS SECRETARY SIDESTEPS
EVERY QUESTION.
>> HOW COULD ANYONE BE THAT
IRRESPONSIBLE?
>> [SILENCE].
>> ISN'T THAT WHAT THE PRESIDENT
SAYS ABOUT MISHANDLING
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
HOW CAN PRESIDENT BIDEN BE
TRUSTED WITH AMERICAN SECRETS?
>> HIS LAWYERS DID THE RIGHT
THING.
>> HE HAD A CLOSET WITH
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
>> AGAIN, AGAIN.
HE WAS SURPRISED THAT THE
RECORDS WERE THERE.
HE SPOKE TO THIS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
DANA, NOTHING TO SEE HERE CROWD,
WHO TALKED ABOUT ONLY TEN AS IF
ONE IS NOT ENOUGH TO PROSECUTE.
NOW WE FIND ADDITIONAL BOX.
WE DON'T HOW MANY DOCUMENTS ARE
IN THAT AT A DIFFERENT LOCATION.
HOW DOES THIS IMPACT THIS
INVESTIGATION?
>> IF I WAS THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS OFFICE, I AM OUT.
THERE IS NOTHING I CAN DO.
I KNOWLEDGE THERE ARE MORE.
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THE COUNSEL'S
OFFICE OR THE CHIEF OF STAFF ALL
RIGHT SAID, LOOK IN ALL OF THE
PLACES.
LOOK ANYWHERE.
IT'S TWO OR THREE MONTHS DOWN
THE ROAD AND THEY FIND ANOTHER
BOX.
YOU ARE IRRESPONSIBLE.
THAT'S WHAT HE SAID ABOUT THE
OTHER FORMER PRESIDENT.
THEY DELAYED IN TELLING PEOPLE
THAT IT HAD HAPPENED.
ED IS A REPORTER FOR CBS NEWS.
IN THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS CORPS.
HE WAS FRUSTRATED BY THE STONE
WALLING ON THE TIMING.
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO COMMIT ON
THE SPECIFIC OF THE DOCUMENTS,
BUT THE FACT THAT THEY HAD THE
INFORMATION BEFORE THE
MID-TERMS.
THEY HELD ON TO IT AND IT ONLY
CAME OUT LATER IN JANUARY.
IT'S A LEGITIMATE QUESTION ABOUT
COMMUNICATIONS.
I DON'T THINK THAT SHOULD BE
STONE WALLED.
EVEN IF THE ANSWER IS RIGHT, WE
SHOULD HAVE TOLD YOU EARLIER.
BUT SHE DOESN'T EVEN HAVE THAT.
YOU COULD ARGUE THESE 2 THINGS
ARE DIFFERENT.
YES, THEY ARE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS BUT THIS AND THAT.
YOU CAN'T ARGUE THAT PRESIDENT
BIDEN HAS COMMUNICATED IT MORE
EFFECTIVELY.
IT'S ONLY BAD WHEN THE OTHER
SIDE DOES IT ONLY GO SO FAR.
PRESIDENT BIDEN GOT BACK TO THE
WHITE HOUSE AND WALKED BY THE
PRESS CORPS AND DIDN'T TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS.
HE WILL HAVE TO ANSWER SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS.
HE MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO READ IT
OFF A CARD NEXT TIME.
>> YES, HE WAS READING.
JESSE, YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
OFFICE AT PENN HAD FINANCING
FROM CHINA.
IN ADDITION TO THAT, JONATHAN
TURLEY SAID FOR DOCUMENTS TO BE
REMOVED SOMEBODY HAS TO REQUEST
THEY BE REMOVED FOR THOSE
DOCUMENTS TO BE IN ONE LOCATION
AND NOW TWO LOCATIONS.
BIDEN WAS WORKING ON A BOOK ON
UKRAINE.
>> WELL, I AM SURE IT WAS GHOST
WRITTEN.
[LAUGHING].
I DON'T KNOW WHAT BIDEN IS
DOING.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE 10 DOCUMENTS
AND COUNTING.
AT THE END OF THIS HE COULD HAVE
MORE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS OUT
THERE THAN DONALD TRUMP HAD AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
I AM KEEPING A LITTLE TALLY
HERE.
IT'S FUNNY THAT HE WAS SURPRISED
TO FIND THAT THEY HAD THESE
DOCUMENTS IN THE CLOSET.
I AM SURE HE WILL BE SURPRISED
TO FIND OUT THE CHINESE WIDER
HIS FAMILY $6 MILLION.
THE STORY SAID THEY DISCOVERED
AT LEAST ONE ADDITIONAL BATCH.
AT LEAST.
THERE IS MORE COMING.
WE KNOW BIDEN HAS BEEN SIFTING
THROUGH DOCUMENTS STORED AT
LOCATION.
JOE ONLY GOES TO DELAWARE.
WHERE ARE THESE LOCATIONS?
HE HAS THE U-PENN CENTER THAT
THE CHINESE FUNDED.
THE ONLY OTHER PLACE WAS IN
GEORGETOWN.
WHERE HUNTER GOT THE KEY.
THERE WAS A MR. DONG FROM CHINA.
HUNTER WAS BRINGING STRIPPERS IN
THERE.
HIGHLY SURE PLACE WITH HUNTER
BROUGHT STRIPPERS TO HAVE SEX
WITH.
HOW SECURE IS THIS U-PENN
CENTER.
DO THEY HAVE MOTION SENSEOR
LASER BEAMS.
IT'S NEXT TO A STEAK HOUSE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S FORT KNOX.
WHY HE IS CLEANING OUT THE
U-PENN BIDEN DOCTOR.
-- CENTER.
WHY SEND A WOMAN TO DO THAT.
SHE IS THE TOP CAMPAIGN LAWYER.
SHE WAS THE TOP WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL.
USED TO WORK FOR BARACK OBAMA.
THEN SHE LEAVES AND DISCOVERS
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS?
I AM NOT A CONSPIRACY THEORIST.
MAYBE OBAMA IS TRYING TO SET JOE
UP.
IT'S FUNNY HOW YOU CAN GET PAID
AS A POLITICIAN.
CHINA IS LAUNDER MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO PAY JOE.
JOE WAS BRINGING IN A $1 MILLION
A YEAR SALARY FROM THE CHINESE,
THAT CAME DIRECTLY FROM THE
CHINESE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
JESSICA, LISTEN TO SOME SOUND WE
HAVE FROM JOE IN 2018, I
BELIEVE.
>> LOOK, MY UNDERSTANDING -- I
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS ANYMORE.
>> NOW WE KNOW FOR 6 YEARS HE
HAD CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS NOT
THIS ONE LOCATION BUT AT LEAST
TWO LOCATIONS.
AND THAT HIS ADMINISTRATION BOTH
THE WHITE HOUSE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE MADE
A DECISION TO NOT SAY ANYTHING
UNTIL AFTER THE MID-TERMS WHEN
THEY KNEW ABOUT IT BEFORE THE
MID-TERMS.
THAT WOULD NOT FAIR.
>> IT'S OBVIOUSLY NOT GOOD.
HE SHOULD NOT HAVE HAD
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
NO ONE SHOULD BE USING WHAT
TRUMP AND WHAT BIDEN HAD TO
JUSTIFY HE DID IT.
IT WAS WRONG.
THEY COULD HAVE SAID THE
PRESIDENT FEELS TOMORROW.
SOMETHING HE WAS NOT AWARE OF
AND HAS TREATED THIS SERIOUSLY
FOR HIS 50 YEAR CAREER.
WE ARE COOPERATING.
I DON'T THINK THE DOCUMENTS WILL
GET AS HIGH AS THE MAR-A-LAGO
COUNT.
RIGHT NOW IT'S AT TEN AND TRUMP
WAS 300 PLUS AND 25 TOP SECRET.
BUT EVEN ONE IS A PROBLEM.
I WAS ON YESTERDAY WITH FORMER
CONGRESSMAN DOUG COLLINS.
HE MADE AN IMPORTANT POINT HOW
CAREERS ARE DESTROYED FOR RANK
LEVEL MILITARY FOLKS.
THEY CAN'T WORK AGAIN.
DISHONORABLE DISCHARGE IF YOU
MISHANDLE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
THAT'S HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS.
THERE IS A NARRATIVE GOING
AROUND THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
IS GETTING OFF EASY FOR THIS BY
THE MEDIA.
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
CNN HAS BEEN WALL-TO-WALL.
IT'S EXHAUSTING LIBERALS.
I DON'T WANT TO SEE IT ANYMORE.
WE UNDERSTAND IT'S BAD.
AND MSNBC IS TALKING ABOUT IS
CONSTANTLY, SOMETHING THAT
DESTROYED THE MERIT AFTER A BUMP
GOING TO THE BORDER.
>> WHO SAID THERE WAS A BORDER
BUMP?
>> THE POLLING HAS YET TO COME
OUT.
>> THE HOPE FOR BUMP.
>> NOW EVERYONE IS TALKING ABOUT
THIS.
IT'S BAD.
I DIRECT EVERYONE.
KARL ROVE HAD HIS WHITE BOARD UP
YESTERDAY AS TO WHY DONALD TRUMP
AND WHAT BIDEN DID ARE
DIFFERENT.
THE COOPERATION PART IS KEY.
THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN NO FBI
AGENCY SHOWING UP AT MAR-A-LAGO
IF THEY HAD NOT STONE WALLED FOR
MONTHS.
>> GREG, NOW WE HAVE FOUND OUT
THAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
HASN'T BEEN HONEST WITH US.
KARINE-JEAN PIERRE SKIPPED PETER
DOOCY'S QUESTION TO SUGGEST
HEARD THERE MAY HAVE BEEN
A SECOND BOX.
ISN'T IT TIME TO GO GUNS
ABLAZING INTO THE HOUSE?
>> WHAT I SAID WHAT IS GOOD FOR
THE GOOSE IS GOOD FOR THE
GANDER.
I ONLY SAY WHAT IS GOOD FOR THE
GOOSE.
WHAT IS IT ABOUT THE BIDENS
LEAVING IMPORTANT STUFF
EVERYWHERE.
HUNTER LEAVING STRIPPER BABIES
AND LAPTOPS ALL OVER THE PLACE
AND THE DAUGHTER LEAVING A GUN
IN THE TRASH CAN AND ASHLEY'S
DIARY FROM A HALFWAY HOUSE.
THESE ARE IMPORTANT THINGS.
JOE IS A REGULAR JOHNNY
APPLESEED WITH CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS.
LOOK AT THIS.
>> ARE THOSE AN ADDITIONAL
BATCH?
>> LET'S TAKE A LOOK, SHALL WE?
WHAT ARE THESE PICTURES OF
A BOOK DEPOSITIORY IN TEXAS.
IT'S 1963.
THAT LOOKS LIKE A YOUNG JOE
BIDEN.
>> ARE YOU SAYING?
>> IT'S POSSIBLE.
THIS IS A BILL FOR HAIR
IMPLANTS.
LOOK!
I AM TIRED OF BEING NICE ABOUT
THIS.
THIS CAME UP UNDER TRUMP I KNEW
IT WAS NOTHING.
MAYBE THIS IS NOTHING TOO, BUT
YOU HAVE TO GO BACK.
JESSICA, IT WAS WORSE.
IT WAS 100 TIMES WORSE WHEN THIS
CAME OUT ABOUT TRUMP.
YOU HAD A HISTORIAN SUGGESTING
EXECUTING TRUMP AND MICHAEL
HAYDEN RETREATED THAT.
I AM GOING ALL IN.
>> EXECUTION?
>> NO, I WILL WAIT FOR THE FACTS
TO COME OUT.
RIGHT NOW IT'S SAFE TO SAY THIS
IS PERHAPS THE WORST THING THAT
HAPPENED SINCE THE CIVIL WAR AND
WORSE THAN 9-11 AND WORSE THAN
THE CIVIL WAR.
AND THE RED HOT CHILE PEPPERS.
>> A CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS?
>> WE HAVE A CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS.
WE ARE NOT LIKE, THAT I CAN'T
EVEN PULL THAT OFF.
>> NO, WE ARE NOT LIKE THAT.
>> WE ARE BETTER PEOPLE, JESS
ACHE.